[Musique]
alors comme ça batman ça sera en quelque
sorte l'homme de l'année faisant
imploser tous les sondages de popularité
les motifs obsédant d'une jeunesse
débridée mais cependant lucide qui
n'avait plus depuis belle lurette le
héros positive à se mettre sous la dent
franchement c'est un sentiment humain on
aurait presque eu l' envie de
démissionner vu l'ampleur de la tâche et
essayer de débusquer la faille dans le
système vérifier qu'au fond tout labat
magna avait bien préparé le lit douillet
du film de l'année et si on avait
échappé à l'envers de force et de l'été
en y mettant il est vrai un peu de
conscience professionnelle on pourrait
s'étonner du phénomène
quelle surprise une files d'attentes
présent dans l'une des cinquante sept
salles parisiennes aujourd'hui le
directeur de warner france steve robin
avec nous c'est roger rabbit qui entrait
dans les 35 40 milles
le premier jour bon batman sera jugé
ensuite j'espère que après tout ça
on verra cette année un chiffre 40 me à
sa coupe et je veux pas
alors vous c'est un beau navet wazlax il
est bien sans plus pas formidable du
coup ça a été génial
il est complètement nul ce fils n'avait
pas boire j'étais bien mais je regarde
beaucoup de les avoir en mai
et encore on respire mieux quand on sait
qu'en france on n'a rien vu de la batman
bien par rapport aux états unis
[Musique]